what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and a lot of people are talking about
returning to the MCU a lot of older
Marvel characters some characters who
have died some characters who are
presumed to be dead and some characters
who kind of just went away we're talking
about spectral Vision Paul betney who
plays Vision has confirmed that he is
returning to the MCU to play Vision at
least one more time and now the only
questions about this are how and when
well fortunately for us we seem to know
how and when especially if you consider
the Scarlet Witch is not done yet in the
MCU and she will be returning as well
and there is a lot of story left with
the Scarlet witch with vision and with
their children that Wanda created in
Wanda Vision there is still a lot of
story to tell from the events of Wanda
Vision to what is going on now to the
Scarlet Witch returning there's a lot
that's going to happen and it looks like
they're not being too shy about it
anymore plus the person that tore them
apart Thanos might be returning as well
actor Josh Brolin who plays Thanos has
hinted that he might not be done
specifically as Thanos in the MCU so a
lot to break down today if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest MCU news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 and Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items or DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
also quick update about that Deadpool 3
trailer we have recently spotted Kevin
fige wearing a Deadpool 3 hat with an
official Deadpool 3 logo on it which is
a great indicator that the trailer
really is coming less than a week from
now this upcoming Sunday Super Bowl
Sunday and whether you caught my last
video or didn't about the Deadpool 3
trailer it sounds like everything is
still the same and a lot of reports are
lining up stating that during the Super
Bowl we are going to get a Super Bowl TV
spot that's kind of a teaser and then
after Marvel will release the full
trailer online on YouTube so keep an eye
out for that and of course if we hear
anything else we'll do another video on
it but Paul betney has been really
talkative lately he recently attended
Megacon 2024 where he talked a lot and
confirmed that he will indeed be back as
Vision at Megacon he took questions from
fans and one fan asked in any way shape
or form will vision return or are you
going to return to the MCU and after a
long pause Paul betney said this well
yeah I mean why wouldn't I yes
100% so not shy about it at all no
beating around the bush no cryptic
messaging no vagueness at all he was
very clear yes 100% and what he said is
true why wouldn't he they did set up a
story for spectral vision and Wanda
Vision remember at the end the vision
the real Vision that we knew that
technically wasn't real because Wanda
created him at that time gave all of the
memories that he had to the spectral
vision and that essentially overloaded
spectral vision and he ran away and he's
still out there so they weren't just
going to leave that open of course as
fans we really want that story to be
concluded and it looks like that is
indeed the plan for Marvel Studios so
vision is confirmed to be returning to
the MCU but like I said the only
questions now are how and when but also
why well the first part of the why
answers itself because they already set
up the story for him so of course they
need to finish it now don't get me wrong
they could always leave it and fans
could be mad but they could always leave
it but luckily for us they aren't but as
far as the second part of the why well
the Scarlet Witch at this point in time
there isn't a ton we know about the
upcoming solo Scarlet Witch film we've
gotten reports about the movie pretty
much ever since Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness came out insiders
have stated yes they do have plans for
Wanda the Scarlet Witch in the MCU and
they are going to give her her true own
film plus Kevin fige came out and pretty
much confirmed that she is still alive
when he was asked about whether she died
on wgore mountain or not he said if you
notice right before the mountain falls
on her you can see a little red light
flash so basically he told us that she
used her powers to essentially not die
now as far as her solo story is
concerned it's really going to get
picked up and start again during the
Agatha darkhold diary series from what
we have heard about this series it is
going to have at least one of Wanda's
children maybe possibly both but it is
going to specifically Focus on her son
Wiccan or Billy as we knew him in the
show it'll specifically focus on him
because he is the one with the magical
abilities unlike his brother Tommy who
is speed in the comics who is very fast
but doesn't exactly have magical
abilities so Billy or Wiccan is going to
be working with Agatha in the darkhold
diary series and apparently according to
some recent reports Agatha will clarify
and make it perfectly clear that Wanda's
kids are real yes she created them and
yes they went away but but something
about their Spirits or their souls and
reincarnation makes them real we've also
heard that they are going to explore the
witches Road and there is a big
connection to Wanda with the witch's
Road not only of course in the comics
but apparently that's where she could be
at right now the witch's road is a
different PL or realm of existence where
only Sorcerers can access it's also said
that once you enter the witch's Road
it's really hard to find a person inside
of the witch's Road from outside the
magic inside is is so powerful that it
makes it really hard to detect somebody
inside of it which is a reason why
people may believe inside the MCU that
the Scarlet Witch really is dead but
according to some recent reports by the
end of the Agatha darkhold diary series
they will attempt to enter the witch's
Road and perhaps they might see Wanda
there now several Insider reports from
the past state that Wanda or the Scarlet
Witch is not going to be in the Agatha
darkhold diary series however she will
be mentioned it's also said that the
witches Road could be the very last
episode of the series so this could set
up the solo Adventures for the Scarlet
Witch that are going to be coming in the
MCU so we know that they have plans for
the Scarlet Witch and we know that they
have plans for vision so naturally of
course to conclude this story in the
Multiverse Saga of Wanda Vision the two
will come together the other side of
Wanda's kids was supposed to be explored
in Vision Quest a show where Vision
returned and was essentially supposed to
be a Young Avengers show with vision
sort of leading the Young Avengers and
one of his children being a part of that
speed so you have two different stories
going on with two of the kids of Wanda
and vision this was originally the plan
for Marvel Studios however we do know
that Marvel Studios is indeed making a
Young Avengers project this was made
very clear by the ending of the Marvels
where we see Kamala Khan meet Kate
Bishop talk about assembling a Young
Avengers team and talk about ant-man's
daughter and unfortunately we have heard
some reports that state vision quest
really isn't happening anymore but what
is really happening now is just a
straight up Young Avengers film this
however is not confirmed we don't know
that this is true yet and since Paul
betney says that he is going to be
returning he very well could return for
a Vision Quest project however at the
same time we do know that he will
probably enter armor Wars as well just
based off of the story that we know it
would make sense that Vision who was of
course supposed to be Ultron who of
course was created by Tony Stark and
Bruce Banner would be in the movie
because the movie is about what happens
when Tony Stark's technology falls into
the wrong hands and although this
particular spectral Vision was not
directly created by Tony Stark he was
created by sword he was definitely
indirectly created by Tony Stark because
Tony Stark created the first Vision so
overall the story of all of these
different characters Wanda Vision their
two kids Agatha it's all eventually
leading to the Scarlet Witch returning
Vision returning and their family
uniting once more all of them now being
real her children being real in some way
shape or form be it reincarnation or
something else vision of course is real
physically and now has the memories of
the other Vision making it to where he
can be pretty close to the other vision
and the Scarlet Witch will return So a
family reunion is happening soon but
hopefully it's a good reunion and not a
bad one especially since Thanos could
return to the MCU like I mentioned Josh
Brolin has recently teased that he could
be returning as Thanos in an interview
with comicbook.com about Dune part two
Brandon Davis asked him if Thanos could
show up again in the MCU and Josh Brolin
said this you know I hear kind of like
through the grape vine that they're
going to bring him back now right away
when I hear this I don't specifically
think that he's going to be involved
with Wanda Vision their new family or
anything like that at all what I do
think he would be involved with is
Avengers Secret Wars in which I would
hope there would be some sort of a
confrontation between him and the
Scarlet Witch kind of something similar
to what we got in Avengers endgame where
Wanda sees Thanos who's not the same
Thanos but she says you took everything
from me and he says I don't even know
who you are I'd like something like that
to happen if Thanos is going to return
and the Scarlet Witch is finally going
to be reunited with her family she might
see him as a super threat to her now
real family that she finally has and
might want to kill him for good this
time but for sure he would return as a
variant and of course not the same
Thanos who died and Avengers ingame
either of them since there were two that
died so really a lot of stuff happening
on the front for the Scarlet Witch and
vision in the MCU plus not to mention
their kids Billy and Tommy Wiccan and
speed they could of course go on to be a
part of the Young Avengers project that
Marvel Studios is developing right now
so a lot of exciting things on this
front let me know what you think in the
comments down below and let me know what
you would like to see as far as the
story is concerned please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on the MCU you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof